As a reminder, what's now examined as one of the OCL Postcondition Constraints,
specifying what happens when a user moves the handle.
Remember, there are direct and indirect effects.
And this, in here, we're talking about the direct effect.
This particular constraint says that when the handle is moved,
we expect the handle position to be in a different place.
This says just what we would expect.
After the user moves the handle, the handle is in the expected position.
Note several things about the specification.
For the first, because it's a direct effect, it's very simple.
And that's exactly the kind of thing we like to have in an event handler.
Event handlers have to be very fast, because there's lot's of events, and
therefore, they have to do simple things and we'd hope that the OCL expression,
which is specifying that, is similarly simple.
Second it doesn't say anything about what is happening to the viewport.
That's an indirect effect.
This is the responsibility of that display association.
And we will get to how we're going to deal with that in awhile.